welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the punisher and
in this video we're breaking down the
brand new
shongxi and the ten rings trailer thing
fang fume
i want you in my room as we're gonna be
going over all the easter eggs
things you missed and also discussing
our thoughts on what could be happening
in the movie
some spoilers are in order so if you
don't anything potentially ruined from
the comics or what we've heard on the
film
then i highly recommend you check out
before i carotize your ass
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the shangchi trailer
okay so we start off with a shot of five
of the ten rings
and they're pretty much going to become
the mcguffin of the movie
in this source material they were
originally ones that you wore around
your fingers
and each included a power on them that
allowed the bearer to have a certain
ability
this included things like mind control
liking the thumbs up button
shooting lightning and even creating a
fake reality
however i kind of think that with this
following so close to the infinity saga
that marvel have decided to move away
from them
and do something completely different so
that we don't just think
it's like poetry they rhyme i haven't
seen bangles this popping since eternal
flame
god damn i have thought about this a lot
since the last trailer
i think that it would be cool if these
bracelets turned out to be rings worn by
dragons
and that would mean they could stay true
to the source material whilst also
changing it up for humans
in the trailer we do see what maybe
thing fume however
several people have come out and said
that this is a different dragon
in the funko pop lineup we know there is
one called the protector
so potentially this is a cousin of his
might even be
his dad and then we get this thing where
the dragon's dad son hates him because
he's been a drag on his life
and shang chi also hates his dad too
which again
is like poetry they rhyme now we cut to
the ten rings flag
which is something that has appeared in
several mcu films already
initially it showed up at the start of
iron man when tony was apparently
captured by the organization
however them rings must allow you to
wreck on stuff as this is what we now
see
this also looks like it takes place in
ancient china and we know from the first
trailer that we will get flashbacks to a
big battle then
i kind of think that we will see a young
mandarin and
how he got those lovely lovely bangles
should call it the ten bangles
they could have potentially made him
immortal and this would explain how he's
able to live for so long
creating this organization however he
does want his son to prove that he's
strong enough to carry them
and who knows we may even get somewhat
of an ego to him
in which he has had several children
over the millennia that have all failed
him
again it's sort of like polish i'll stop
with that now
we know that shang chi falls out with
his father and in order to be able to
fight him
i think he will have to travel to this
island to be taught by michelio's
character
jiangnan now we know from the first
trailer that the pair fight
so it makes sense that this is the place
he would level up at
in the new look she seems to be
controlling the elements and space
around her
which will likely lead to chongqi
learning how to do the same
though he's typically not a meta human
in the comics there have been different
interpretations where he's gained
certain powers
and i think that they will probably be
leaning into that with this scene
and of course the rings there is another
shot of the mandarin controlling water
in front of his son
so yeah i think that's probably the most
likely thing now next we hear that
chongqi
is very much split down the middle
between his mother and father
this clearly shows the conflict that he
has as a person and it'll be interesting
to see as he wrestles with these aspects
she is likely will put him off becoming
a bad guy and i think that the island we
see
might even be related to her and her
kingdom maybe his mother even took him
to this island to hide him away from his
dad
and when he arrived she potentially
tried to stop him we can't catch a scene
where the mandarin is firing the ten
bangles at a woman in a woodland area
so potentially this is where he kills
zeld stop calling them bagels as well
now at one point we see her training him
in a water room
and this could be her showing him how to
master the elements
and it might be what leads to him having
powers we also know that he has an
estranged sister in the film
so he could end up teaming up with her
after realizing he'd rather be more like
his mother than his dear old dad
potentially his sister turned away from
their father too
and this might be what made him lean so
hard into pursuing chongqi as the next
in line
we see some of his training growing up
and also death dealer who appears at his
dad's side
death dealer does fight chongqi at one
point so i'm guessing he's oldest crap
too
and who knows maybe the mandarin has the
ability to pass on the immortality
if that theory is indeed correct however
it could just be a mantle that people
wear
depending on what version they go with
but either way we do know that it's the
same actor playing the main one
now the death dealers appear in the
trailer at several points fighting
and it seems like they may be the right
hand of the villain we also see the ten
rings training room
and can tell this from the markings on
the floor this is probably
where they train the death dealers and
test whether they can join the group
it's very batman begins the or rather
the league of assassins
slash shadows depending on what you read
also yeah why did batman a dude who
doesn't kill
join the league of assassins no no never
mind we're not we'll not go off on that
tangent now
we learned the mandarin sends his best
men after chongqi to prove that they
can't kill him
which will show how strong he is this
sort of ties back to the whole ego thing
of testing his kids to see if they're
worthy
and with such a big empire he has to
make sure they on kylo ren
next we cut to the fighting arena which
is a big part of the trailer
and here it has some really cool reveals
in the last one everyone thought there
was a captain america shield hidden out
there
but i actually think that it might have
been the symbol for madrapura
somewhere that we know is a safe haven
for criminals i would absolutely
love it if this scene was set here and
it makes sense with the neon lights
you know you know those kids love those
neon lights now madrapa is of course a
fictional asian country
that's known for harboring criminals and
therefore it makes sense why the
abomination would be laying low there
in the trailer we can also see that he's
way closer to his comic book incarnation
than he was
originally and perhaps he has mutated
over the years and changed up
sort of in the same way that the hulk
started to look a lot more like mark
ruffalo
i know a lot of that was down to the
effects getting better but it would be
interesting to see if they brought that
into the plot too
he has the girls and also some pants on
yay now he's rumored to be in she-hulk
as well so it'll be interesting to see
how he's brought back into the mcu now
we also know that the thunderbolts
or rather an evil superhero team is
being formed by val
aka madame hydra who popped up in falcon
in the winter soldier
interviews at the time of the finale
with her also said she'll be showing up
in black widow too
so it'll be interesting to see if she
sort of becomes the nick fury for the
bad guys
with suicide squad i was always a bit
good that they didn't slot the villains
into other dc eu movies beforehand
so that they could quote unquote
avengers the team together for a big bad
guy movie
i felt that because warner brothers
rushed justice league that they should
have taken their time forming the
suicide squad
but looks like marvel are doing what i
would have preferred and slotting the
villains into things before they form
the group
now we also see wong and i guess that
the guy must be skinned to be doing this
man's wanted some of that hulka hulka
burning fudge up close
and maybe he's broke after spending
money on those tuna melts that contain
zero percent tuna say topical jokes at
the channel guys
everyone said we were getting our first
asian superhero
but we had one all along when it comes
to wong
now there is the possibility that this
isn't him but benedict
wong and simulu were caught hanging out
whilst this was being filmed
so i think it's probably our number one
superstar now we get more of the
restaurant scene from the first trailer
namely the mandarin kicking the crap out
of a guy there and this clearly shows
his son first hand the kind of man he is
young shong seems pretty shocked and
this probably planted the idea that his
dad was a bad guy
and that he also hated wearing bangles
now we learned that shong
tried to change his name and start a new
life and we see him on the run
but it's clear that his dear old daddy
pursued him next we see some quick
cuts including taser fate sorry razor
fist
a man with a racer for a fist who we
know from the behind the scenes stuff
is a mercenary center hunt down shong
whether this happens before the reveal
or not we don't know
but it does look like this scene takes
place in the same part of the film that
the car chase does
later on we catch him in the helicopter
and at the snowy ice base that feels
very james bundy
there's also shong taking part in the
fighting tournament and also yeah i know
i'm pronouncing it shong but that's
actually what kevin feige said recently
so stop writing your comment and also
yeah i know my voice sounds like crap
it's like it's like 6am in the morning
now we then get a shot of the mandarin
and his boy fighting and trying to pull
the rings from one another
kind of feel like they might introduce
something like whoever is worthy
and whoever's heart is true can wield
the rings and pull them back
now that's all the easter eggs i spotted
and just as a sort of general review of
the trailer
i have to say i really really liked it
weirdly
simulu got a lot of backlash when the
first trailer dropped
so they're clearly laying into the tony
length stuff a lot more here
but yeah still a great trailer i thought
martial art it's always something i've
been interested in
and i know from speaking to people
behind the scenes that black widow has
some brilliant action
scenes in it so i'm glad that marvel is
leaning heavily into doing this sort of
thing
this is going to open up the door to a
lot of different elements in the mcu
and simulu definitely has quite a big
career ahead of him
if he nails this role kind of a shame
they can't really play up his part and
are having to lean into others as he's
obviously the main character
and this movie needs to do well in china
to make marvel continue down this path
expect some pandering with the mandarin
i think
i don't know i just said that because it
rhymes but it's not like this channel is
good
so i doubt you're surprised now the
trailer is also packed with tons of
references to the comics too
so i think it's really gonna be
something special and i can't wait to
see what comes next as we start to ramp
up the marketing for it
now i have heard that marvel actually
have this spider-man no way home trailer
and post already
but that they're focusing on this film
black widow and loki first before
putting anything out there
this means it might be as late as the
end of july slash start of
august before we get a first look at
that but i'm kind of hoping that sony
just step in and say
hey we need to promote this because
there's no way
homes i'm waiting another couple of
months for that trailer i want it now
either way this was a good one and i
hope you enjoyed the video sorry it's so
early here and i'm just so tired now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want to
watch another trailer breakdown that's a
lot better than this one
then check out our one for loki episode
4 which will be linked on screen right
now
some cool little images in it and
definitely a lot of things to take
so definitely go and give it a watch and
i love you forever
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video abby paul
i'll see you next time take care peace